vous vous souvenez en 2009 d'un petit
film intitulé paranormal activity qui
flanquaient une trung tous les diables
aux amateurs de sallesobscures war et
bien le moment est venu de clore la
série avec son dernier opus
plongez vous dans l'univers de
paranormal activity et découvrez ce qui
vous attend dans paranormal activity 5
cost dimension au cinéma tout a commencé
avec katie et micah tient vicat contente
au revoir à adieu mis cap puis on a fait
la connaissance de christie la soeur de
cathy et du fils de christine hunter
sauf s'est pas passé loin
ainsi au nom tard voilà plus tard on a
eu un petit aperçu de l'enfance de katie
et kristi apparemment tout est normal
ah non on dirait que christie s'est fait
un nouveau copain ça se présente peut
très bien
finalement le nouveau copain de
christie's be et l'imaginaire ni
franchement très sympa si vous faites le
compte
il a pas mal de victimes à son actif
voilà donc ce qu'on sait jusqu'à présent
depuis leur enfance christie et katic
onesta démon nommé toby logan vers le
hisser sa congrégation de sorcières ont
vraisemblablement encourager leurs
relations relations à laquelle n'est pas
étranger le fils de christine hunter
premier garçon de la famille depuis les
années 30
ce qui nous amène à ce que nous ne
savons pas encore
comme par exemple à quoi ressemble copie
à ce que cherche exactement à ce que
sont devenus les filles après la mort de
leur mère qu'est ce que tous vivent eux
à hunter le fils de christie c'est quoi
cette congrégation qu'est devenu un
auteur et cathy qu'est ce qu'elle
devient pour avoir des réponses à ces
questions il faut aller voir paranormal
activity 5 cost dimension au cinéma en
3d